hello and welcome to this video playing
vball Matata I'm not a particularly good
Squire against this person one win two
losses that's not great okay so let's
see what is staying play him a stone
wall here again stretchy this is really
a pretty risky ADM as white has good
chances to play your form okay not yet
295 but you have to check those moves as
e6 is simply a is simply an under attack
or not so i'ma text wrong as unprotected
is the right word so I pushed you for
pretty quickly it wasn't strictly
necessary to do this in this particular
situation but it's normally good so
let's do it okay so i cant it twice on
d5 or can take on f5 both both is
certainly good for white but what are we
going to play okay i think i'll take
care not thinking for too long about it
I already see what the compensation is
him he cannot if you move the night if I
the same yeah so okay I think taking
here makes makes sense in any case and
now check maybe just really one putting
more pressure on the porn now it cannot
be bad even though you can argue that
there could be better moose I mean
really let's do it it's a simple move d
4 is always going to play your form
which is not ideal age 6 so a simple
move would be Quincy to hear it is
actually ok on 95 I have a good mood
deform simple and good it's not so clear
what is his movers doesn't have anything
particularly convincing at least I
didn't see anything for books is six ok
[Music]
even night h4 comes into consideration
in the citizens in this position
I came after the roof yeah I think I do
this actually centralized everything and
give me a retreat square for the Queen
where I'm not blocking any peace it
cannot play you for and this is what
counts okay so what is this night age
for is possible and it's not preparing
anything yet I can't even go for g-form
[Music]
just aiming to cover the pawn on f5 a
bishop a six maybe
I can trade this nice plane quickly now
not sure yeah I mean g4 it's not
something that helps me a great deal or
that feels necessary in any way f5 isn't
exactly under fire okay if I move the
night now I'm on that diagonal which is
quite nice I just don't know where the
night is well positioned
I wonder if before I so move actually I
can take that you five is hanging but
doing all that much okay let's let's
speed up I'm taking too long looking at
this position here it is good for white
anyway and I'm wasting time here Thank
You Muslim
going from 94 or what I don't know I
take it
and c5 night cool what is he doing time
warning why does that work it doesn't
okay
[Music]
threatening mate so all 95 was my idea
what you can take f6 huh I think it
still should be played
in 97 I was thinking is there something
else i was taking this yeah I've got
Queen d8 if everything else fails check
let's do it you'll be able to win this
even with little time
yeah that should be possible check got a
lot of stuff on the dark squares that
makes it a bit easier to have to play
[Music]
check check check black resigned okay
wow it's so kind of kind of a tricky all
that after the opening position you
would assume that things would be over
quickly I probably didn't play it to the
best possible here white is more or less
winning but yeah you still have to
convert 69 th for the computer just goes
for this yeah it's kind of the most
natural move going also near black skin
which maybe I wanted to be too clever or
something which I don't think right yes
things are still good yeah still a
pretty nice advantage and now I hadn't
decided to go there yeah yeah I'm just
what is kind of Impractical then I'm
down to one minute 12 yeah yeah there
was nothing particularly difficult or
anything I could have could have played
all that a lot we come ya hear this this
I didn't quite get Bishop a6 was winning
okay yeah i was a little bit panicky
already with the time being
no and simply didn't work this really
should win k9h six maybe was checking me
out as possible right okay that holds an
easy win with greedy aid yak here I kind
of lost the thread just taking all so
far too long for simple moves you can
probably play quite a coin anything here
be somewhat better yeah and ikea this is
not a good idea King do you wanna hit
the engine book clearly showing that
something was off yeah he has too much
now with the death too active Jim and I
completely here i will cook f1 I a
completely overlooked herb you should be
six of course I should play what to the
test engine give like this and it's
roughly equal yeah I'll out far too much
counterclaim maybe you can can you can
kill this off more efficiently here 25 I
don't really know the computer wants to
take on d5 this is of course also
possible just take this because blacks
center is totally unsupported it could
be even better I mean this this isn't
working I can I thought 95 isn't that
good okay that's not even the best move
even though it looks pretty devastating
the only black has no development here
and this whole center is a complete mess
so probably you cannot take down the
engine suggest this but after uniform
this is maybe even stronger Black is
just opening up the position with many
weaknesses around and
and bad development so that words would
be even more effective probably then
grabbing on f5 pokey guys thanks for
watching